bonjour à tous je m'appelle jean foyer
j'ai 39 ans et effectivement je suis un
ancien croupier maintenant dans les
cercles jeu de jeux parisiens notamment
l'aviation club de france
est ce que j'ai ce que j ai vécu là bas
est absolument extraordinaire toutes mes
journées et surtout mes nuits je
travaillais surtout de nuit ce sont des
choses je vais pour vous en parler on va
commencer
je vais vous raconter un événement
essentiel qui avait tourné une nuit il
ya de ça à peu près sept ans on avait de
très bons joueurs qui se cherchait en
permanence qui commençait à ceux à se
provoquer à savoir qui était le meilleur
et ils ont décidé un jour fallu nuit de
s'affronter de s'affronter c'est à dire
cette fois ci un de faire ce qu'on
appelle un face à face
d'habitude le poker qu'est-ce que ça s
est un croupier dans un cercle de jeu
avec neuf joueurs tout autour de lui est
bon on aura en moyenne deux gagnants set
perdant si perdant et un dernier qui va
qui va rester à peu près qui aura rien
gagné ni perdu mais là ils font un face
à face ils vont s'asseoir avec chacun
cinquante mille euros devant eux et ça
va jouer gros et ça va jouer toute la
nuit et la partie avance on voit bien
que l'un des deux joueurs commencent à
un petit peu à froncer des sourcils aux
mesures au fur et à mesure que la partie
continue et à 10 heures du matin je vais
m'asseoir à la table pour distribuer et
faire cette table et là l'un des deux
joueurs fait cent cinquante mille euros
et tapis ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
au fur et à mesure qu'on vous allez
jouer au poker vous misez 50 millions
euros vous les perdez vous allez
remettre 50000 euros vous les repères
des donc qu'est ce que vous faites dans
ces cas là vous allez remettre cent
mille euros pour essayer de les regagner
vous les perdez quand même et puis là
vous videz vos poches vous mettez tout
ce que vous avez là il avait cinq cent
cinquante mille euros
il fait tapis il est payé il pense être
le meilleur il a perdu il se prend une
quinte dans les temps malgré ça ils
avaient une formidable poker fait ça
alors là peuvent guère fait je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez
c'est une expression c'est pas une
expression justement c'est la façon dont
vous allez mettre votre visage pour
faire transparaître le moins
d'expression de le moins de sentiments
passent
vous savez pas si vous votre adversaire
qu'on sait bien faire ne sera pas si
vous avez peur si vous êtes content de
votre main vous allez essayer d'être
absolument enfin le plus transparent
possible
il perd il encaisse le coup les il voit
ses jetons partir et puis là il se lève
de sa table il se rend compte qu'il a
perdu cependant ces huit heures pour un
petit problème d'orgueil au départ cinq
cent mille euros
cinq cent mille euros et on va voir qui
va être crispé on va voir son poker face
avec des petits mouvements un peu des
2/3 tics nerveux et on va le voir
pendant l'heure qui va suivre dans le
cercle de jeux marché déambuler un peu
comme comme un zombie comme ça en train
de se parler par moments à lui même ça
ça arrive souvent dans les cercles de
jeu les gens qui ceux qui se lèvent qui
se parlent à eux mêmes ont l'impression
qu'ils sont fous pas du tout il encaisse
les coups
parce que quand vous perdez bon pour
certains ce sera trois mois de salaire
pour certains dans ce cas là ce sera un
petit appartement parisien
faut quand même l'encaissé et derrière
c'est pas rare de voir un joueur qu'on
ne verra pas pendant trois jours parce
qu'il va se coucher dans le noir et il
aura plus la force de se lever
ce sera un petit nerveux break dorn
qu'il devra qu'il devra gérer alors je
me posais une question un petit peu sur
sur le sujet s'affranchir des règles du
jeu ou de la triche pour ma part
j'estime que un croupier n'est pas
forcément la personne la plus compétente
de parler de la triche
je m'explique un croupier sa mission à
lui ça va être d'empêcher la triche sous
toutes ses formes
quoi qu'il se passe et à moi quand on me
demande de parler de la triche c'est un
petit peu comme si on demandait à je
sais pas un pilote de ligne de parler de
son dernier crash avec 200 personnes
dans l'avion enfin c'est bon c'est un
peu bizarre mais je vais quand même vous
dire ce que je sais de la triche au
poker c'est mon domaine de compétence
alors bon
il ya trois grandes familles de triche
au poker la toute première c'est très
simple c'est avec les cartes
vous avez tous certainement cette image
d'une partie de poker au far west avec
des cartes qui se cachent dans les
manches sous la table et puis on annonce
des carrés droit d carré d'as enfin ça
va ça va dans tous les sens c'est très
compliqué dans un casino dans un cercle
de jeux qui dit de la triche comme ça
pourquoi parce que c'est le sait le
croupier qui garde en permanence et qui
va compter les cartes qui va surveiller
où sont les cartes et il va garder en
permanence son paquet de cartes dans la
main quoi qu'il arrive et ça c'est la
première mission c'est ce qu'on nous
apprend en premier c'est de ne jamais
lâcher son paquet de cartes quoi qu'il
arrive ça va tellement loin
cette notion alors il y aura du vécu
mais j'ai pas vécu toutes ces situations
ça va tellement loin que quand vous avez
par exemple un incendie qui se déclare
dans le cercle
ça peut arriver vous devez pas lâcher
vos cartes et normalement vous devez
rester assis même si les flammes se
rapproche et que tout le monde se sauver
vous êtes là avec votre paquet de cartes
si vous avez un hold up de trois
personnes qui rentrent avec de très très
belles cagoule un fusil à pompe à la
main et qui disent à tout le monde mais
en l'air mais le groupe y est il va
faire la même chose il va lever ses
mains avec le paquet de cartes tous
pareils et un dernier exemple si vous
avez même quelqu'un qui qui va faire une
crise cardiaque une rupture d'anévrisme
qui s'effondre vous lâcherez toujours
pas avec votre paquet de cartes toujours
pas vous allez le garder et même si vous
avez des compétences de premiers soins
au pire du pire
vous pourrez lui faire du bouche à
bouche mais votre paquet de cartes à la
main et vous avez même une règle à las
vegas ça s'est pas encore produit en
france
d'après ce que je sais à las vegas cette
règle c'est quand vous avez un joueur
qui meurent pendant une partie de poker
alors qu'ils avaient des cartes en main
donc il était sur un coup il est
considéré à tapis à tapis on l'a vu
c'est à dire que retient et il est mort
on va on va pousser tous ses jetons dans
la partie et là vous avez deux
possibilités soit il y avait des joueurs
un peu jantes lohman qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire ouhlala faut s'occuper
ils ont jeté leurs cartes et puis le
coût est fini on va remettre les jetons
à la personne qui vient de mourir
bon et ce sera pour ces enfants soit il
ya des gens des joueurs ça arrive aussi
qu'ils vont estimer qu'il y a un coup à
jouer un très beau tapis à prendre ils
vont considérer que c'est une
opportunité
et là il ya un vrai vrai dilemme qui va
qui va se produire parce que les joueurs
qui vont se dire il ya quarante mille
dollars
oh là là mais quel quelle tête il avait
gilbert avant avant de mourir pourquoi
pourquoi il pense à ça parce que je ne
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu un cadavre
de près mais la poker faith d'un cadavre
on est sur du très très haut niveau un
lacet voilà donc on va réfléchir où
l'attend qu'est ce que c'était sa
dernière mimiques avant de la vendre
comme c'est ok donc ça c'est les cartes
la deuxième chose c'est les jetons alors
les jetons c'est beaucoup plus basique
essayé de tricher avec les jetons
c'est du vol vous allez essayer de voler
soit le casino le groupe et un croupier
distrait soit un joueur à droite à
gauche
j'ai une anecdote à ce propos on avait
un habitué
un jeune notaire quelqu'un de a priori
très très intègre un très à cheval sur
les règles et ils surveillaient peut
absolument tous les mouvements chacun
alors il venait très régulièrement il a
commencé à perdre pas mal puis beaucoup
puis énormément et puis au bout de
quatre ans un très mauvais après midi il
avait perdu beaucoup d'argent il était
sur des parties très très cher ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que c'est une
stratégie qui peut se passer en nuit
peut se passer aussi sur plusieurs
années au départ vous perdez un peu vous
allez miser de plus en plus pour essayer
de récupérer cet argent c'est une sorte
de fuite en avant
mais bon évidemment c'est un cercle un
cercle vicieux est donc cet après midi
là ça correspondait à la catastrophe de
fukushima
dans les cercles de poker il n'est pas
rare que vous ayez des grands écrans de
télé qui sont répartis un peu dans la
salle et on avait un reportage assez
effrayant sur bfm
je m'en souviens d'ailleurs fukushima
j'ai appris aujourd'hui que c'était les
six ans c'est un très triste
anniversaire
enfin bon bref ça s'était passé ce jour
là et là tous les personnes évidemment
ont eu les yeux rivés sur ces images de
catastrophes et lui qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il en a profité il a profité de la
catastrophe
cauchy ma salade est passé il a fallu
qu'ils trichent
il a eu un geste très très rapide et il
a saisi un jeton 2000 parce qu'ils
jouaient déjà sur une grosse table le
groupe qui a vu un geste très furtive
très rapide il a prévenu son chef de
parti on a regardé les vidéos on vit
dans une époque aujourd'hui modernes
toutes les grosses parties sont
enregistrées par un micro observé par
une ou deux caméras on regarde c'est
facile on voit qu'il a vu on est allé le
voir il a rendu l'argent il a été
interdit de jeux de casino etc et on l'a
plus jamais revu par la suite
alors ça c'est un cas de vol tout à fait
classique la deux la deuxième chose
qu'on peut dire aussi une autre anecdote
un après midi une partie un peu
mouvementée ou saas taquine beaucoup ça
ça use beaucoup il ya surtout deux
joueurs qui se déteste on le sait depuis
de longue date l'un provoque l'autre en
permanence fait des blagues etc
il en rajouter en fait des caisses ok
l'autre joueur qui est qui les prend
comme ça un moment il n'en peut plus il
va prendre une pile de jetons de sang
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
vu des jetons de casino alors gagne par
une couche de plastique dur mais à
l'intérieur il ya du métal ça ça pèse
lourd
il le prend et il s'en sert comme des
munitions il va le visent et il va lui
le faire saigner une arcade sourcilière
et là alors les règles sont un peu c'est
que le chef de la salle le ce qu'on
appelle le floor qui va décider soi
c'est un habitué
donc on va de toute façon on va le faire
sortir celui qui a eu un geste un peu
agressif on va le faire sortir du casino
il reviendra dans une semaine soit on
ramasse les jetons lui laisse de côté
soit on n'aime pas trop trop et on aime
bien la personne qui s'est fait blesser
dans ce cas là on lui donne l'argent
parce que c'était une façon de donner un
peu original mais c'était un bon quand
même
et puis si on n'aime ni l'un ni l'autre
eh ben on garde les jetons de côté puis
ça va tomber non on les pourboires des
croupiers personnel merci c'est un
formule donc voilà pour les jetons et
puis vous avez un troisième une
troisième phase ont triché et là ça
devient très très intéressant est
beaucoup plus complexe puisque c'est
avec les avec les gens avec les
individus les personnes qui sont autour
le poker est très
très permissif vous avez le droit de
mentir d'influencé de provoquer votre
adversaire de bluffer évidemment la
seule chose les seules choses que vous
ayez pas trop le droit de faire c'est de
menacer
on n'est plus à l'époque d'al capone et
puis est insultée on est entre gens tu
le masne normalement enfin bon alors il
y aura du vécu mais j'ai pas vécu toutes
ces situations ça va tellement loin que
quand vous avez par exemple un incendie
qui se déclare dans le cercle
ça peut arriver vous devez pas lâcher
vos cartes et normalement vous devez
rester assis même si les flammes se
rapproche et que tout le monde se sauver
vous êtes là avec votre paquet de cartes
si vous avez un hold up de trois
personnes qui rentrent avec de très très
belles cagoule un fusil à pompe à la
main et qui disent à tout le monde mais
en l'air mais le groupe y est il va
faire la même chose il va lever ses
mains avec le paquet de cartes tous
pareils et un dernier exemple si vous
avez même quelqu'un qui qui va faire une
crise cardiaque une rupture d'anévrisme
qui s'effondre vous lâcherez toujours
pas avec votre paquet de cartes toujours
pas vous allez le garder et même si vous
avez des compétences de premiers soins
au pire du pire
vous pourrez lui faire du bouche à
bouche mais votre paquet de cartes à la
main et vous avez même une règle à las
vegas ça s'est pas encore produit en
france
d'après ce que je sais à las vegas cette
règle c'est quand vous avez un joueur
qui meurent pendant une partie de poker
alors qu'ils avaient des cartes en main
donc il était sur un coup il est
considéré à tapis à tapis on l'a vu
c'est à dire que retient eux il est mort
on va on va pousser tous ses jetons dans
la partie et là vous avez deux
possibilités soit il y avait des joueurs
un peu jean claud man qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire ouhlala faut s'occuper
ils ont jeté leurs cartes et puis le
coup il fini on va remettre les jetons à
la personne qui vient de mourir et ce
sera pour pour ses enfants soit il ya
des gens des joueurs ça arrive aussi
qu'ils vont estimer qu'il y a un coup à
jouer un très beau tapis à prendre ils
vont considérer que c'est une
opportunité
et là il ya un vrai vrai dilemme qui va
qui va se produire parce que les joueurs
qui vont se dire
il ya quarante mille dollars oh là là
mais quel tête il avait gilbert avant
avant de mourir pourquoi pourquoi il
pense à ça parce que je sais pas si vous
avez déjà vu un cadavre de près mais la
poker faith d'un cadavre on est sur du
très très haut niveau là c'est voilà
donc on va réfléchir où l'attend qu'est
ce que c'était sa dernière mimiques
avant de cavan de clamser oui bon ok
donc ça c'est les cartes
la deuxième chose c'est les jetons alors
les jetons c'est beaucoup plus basique
essayé de tricher avec les jetons
c'est du vol vous allez essayer de voler
soit le casino le groupe est un groupe
il est distrait soit un joueur à droite
à gauche
j'ai une anecdote à ce propos on avait
un habitué un jeune notaire quelqu'un de
a priori très très intègre un très à
cheval sur les règles et ils
surveillaient peut absolument tous les
mouvements chacun alors il venait très
régulièrement il a commencé à perdre pas
mal puis beaucoup puis énormément et
puis au bout de quatre ans un très
mauvais après midi il avait perdu
beaucoup d'argent il était sur des
parties très très cher ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est une stratégie qui
peut se passer en nuit peut se passer
aussi sur plusieurs années
au départ vous perdez un peu vous allez
miser de plus en plus pour essayer de
récupérer cet argent c'est une sorte de
fuite en avant
mais bon évidemment c'est un cercle un
cercle vicieux est donc cet après midi
là ça correspondait à la catastrophe de
fukushima
dans les cercles de poker il n'est pas
rare que vous ayez des grands écrans de
télé qui sont répartis un peu dans la
salle et on avait un reportage assez
effrayant sur bfm
je m'en souviens d'ailleurs fukushima
j'ai appris aujourd'hui que c'était les
six ans c'est un très triste
anniversaire
enfin bon bref ça s'était passé ce jour
là et là tous les personnes évidemment
ont eu les yeux rivés sur ces images de
catastrophes et lui qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il en a profité il a profité de la
catastrophe de fukushima
ça l'a dépassé il a fallu qu'ils
trichent
il a eu un geste très très rapide et il
a saisi un jeton 2000
parce qu'ils jouaient déjà sur une
grosse table le croupier a vu un geste
très furtif très rapide il a prévenu son
chef de parti on a regardé les vidéos on
vit dans une époque aujourd'hui
terne toutes les grosses parties sont
enregistrées par un micro observé par
une ou deux caméras on regarde c'est
facile on voit qu'il a vu on est allé le
voir il a rendu l'argent il a été
interdit de jeux de casino etc et on l'a
plus jamais revu par la suite
alors ça c'est un cas de vol tout à fait
classique la deux la deuxième chose
qu'on peut dire aussi une autre anecdote
un après midi une partie un peu
mouvementée où ça se taquinent beaucoup
ça celui de beaucoup il ya surtout deux
joueurs qui se déteste on le sait depuis
de longue date l'un provoque l'autre en
permanence fait des blagues etc
il en rajoute il en fait des caisses ok
l'autre joueur qui est qui les prend
comme ça un moment il n'en peut plus il
va prendre une pile de jetons de sang
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
vu des jetons de casino à l'origine par
une couche de plastique dur mais à
l'intérieur il ya du métal ça pèse lourd
il le prend et il s'en sert comme des
munitions il va le visent et il va lui
le faire saigner une arcatures souffre
sourcilière et là alors les règles sont
un peu ces jeux le chef de la salle le
ce qu'on appelle le floor qui va décider
soi c'est un habitué
donc on va de toute façon on va le faire
sortir celui qui a eu un geste un peu
agressif on va le faire sortir du casino
il reviendra dans une semaine soit on
ramasse les jetons lui laisse de côté
soit on l aime pas trop trop et on aime
bien la personne qui s'est fait blesser
dans ce cas là on lui donne l'argent
parce que c'était une façon de donner un
peu original mais c'était un ton quand
même et puis si on n'aime ni l'un ni
l'autre
eh bien on garde les jetons de côté puis
ça va tomber dans les pourboires des
croupiers personnel merci c'est un
formule donc voilà pour les jetons et
puis vous avez un troisième une
troisième phase ont triché et là ça
devient très intéressant est beaucoup
plus complexe puisque c'est avec les
avec les gens avec les individus les
personnes qui sont autour
le poker est très très permissif vous
avez le droit de mentir d'influencé de
provoquer votre adversaire de bluffer
évidemment la seule chose les seules
choses que vous ayez pas trop le droit
de faire c'est de menacer
on n'est plus à l'époque d'al capone et
puis
et insultés on est entre gens thomann
normalement enfin bon c'est pas toujours
le cas
et excusez moi
tu bluffes marconi vous êtes oui entre
bluffeur et donc que vous avez des cas
où c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de
tricher mais ça arrive quand même
vous avez par exemple le cas de
collusion le cas de collusion c'est très
compliqué à observer c'est quand vous
avez deux joueurs qui s'entendent ça se
fait beaucoup plus grands tournois que
ce qu'on appelle en cash game
je vais peut-être pas trop rentrer dans
les détails quand même la collusion la
wii la collusion c'est quand vous avez
deux joueurs qui vont s'entendre pour en
dégommer un troisième pour lui prendre
tous ses jetons
c'est interdit mais c'est très très dur
à prouver ce qui est l'autre possibilité
de tricher avec les personnes c'est
directement de s'entendre avec le
croupier alors c'est une très mauvaise
idée pour le croupier d'accepter quoi
que ce soit je vous donne un exemple qui
a cassé semble assez anodin dans les
salles de poker vous avez un bad beat
tout à fait à un jackpot tout à fait
particulier qui s'appelle le bad beat
je pense que vous vous êtes peu nombreux
à connaître c'est à dire que c'est un
jeu un jackpot qui s'accumulent avec le
temps et qui va tomber quand il y aura
une configuration extrêmement rare qui
va se produire c'est à dire quand il y
aura un carré d'as battu on a une
expression qui dit qu'il y a que deux
choses qui bat au poker le carré d'as le
premier sas le plus tellement c'est le
smith & wesson
le deuxième c'est la carlingue quinte
flush royale il ya ce moment là toute la
table de tous les joueurs vont se
partager le bad beat
surtout celui qui perd est celui qui
gagne mais aussi tous les autres autour
et donc quand vous avez ce ce jour de
jackpot
les joueurs peuvent très bien venir vous
voir entre le même directement pendant
la partie où pendant que vous êtes en
pause ou même dehors quand ils vous
voient écoute est ce que tu peux te
faire deux trois manipulations
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
évidemment personne ne peut manipuler
les cartes à votre place même le
meilleur des magiciens il n'arrivera pas
à faire un tour quand c'est avec les
mains d'un autre et
il ya des tentations très très fortement
les casinos il faut refuser évidemment
et il faut refuser pas parce que c'est
de l'argent facile si vous voulez enfin
c'est pas très moral mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dans une table de poker
il n'est pas rare que vous ayez en
france à un pari un yakuza votre gauche
a annoncé que c'est un yakuza pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un gros tatouages aux
dragons qui sort de la chemise et puis
lui manque que deux doigts comme ça donc
c'est pas c'est pas très pratique avec
les jetons mais je vais quand même vous
pourrez avoir un digne représentant de
d'une mafia quelle qu'elle soit vous
aurez tout d'un coup un un chef
d'entreprise alors lui on reconnaît pour
deux choses pourquoi parce que c'est le
moins commode de la table pourrait
rigoler toujours avec un presque
gâchette un presque achète pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu scarface c'est celui qui
pressent sur la gâchette et vous en avez
des gens dont le métier c'est de de
tirer sur d'autres dans le jour et puis
de travailler un peu et les cartes la
nuit et est donc le la personne qui de
mauvaise humeur c'est celle qui perd
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent au fur et à mesure et cette
personne elle reste elle grogne mais
elle a ses jetons rennes voit son son
argent partir un peu partout on va
l'appeler une vache à lait enfin on va
l'appeler les autres joueurs vont
appeler une vache à lait et cet exemple
nous les croupiers on l'a un peu appris
avec avec le temps on s'est mis à donner
des noms d'animaux à tous les joueurs
alors au sens propre et au sens figuré
aussi parfois mais surtout au sens
propre je vous donne un exemple
quelqu'un qui perd on va l'appeler un
mouton ou un pigeon un pigeon il ya une
phrase comme ça de paul newman qui est
bien connue qui dit quand tu t'assois
une table de poker et si tu ne vois pas
le pichon au bout d'une demi heure c'est
que le pigeon c'est toi c'est assez vrai
et vous aurez aussi d'autres
comportements un petit peu animalier
vous aurez par exemple des joueurs qui
vont tâcher de ne jamais dépensé qui qui
vont essayer venir que quand ils ont le
jeu max ils en sont sûrs etc
on sent qu'il ya un petit peu d'avarice
là dedans on les appelle les crabes
vous aurez des personnes qui vont
calculer en permanence comme on les
appelle les chouettes alors en fonction
de l'âge on les appelle les vieille
chouette c'est pas très respectueux
c'est comme ça et puis des gens
d'expérience les renards et puis au
sommet de la chaîne alimentaire
vous allez avoir le requin et celui là
il est pas du tout là pour rigoler il
est là pour gagner un maximum d'argent
et on se soucie pas s'il ya des dégâts
alors je vous raconte tout ça je
voudrais terminer sur deux points
ce qu'il faut en tirer c'est pâques
évidemment que le poker c'est dangereux
qu'il faut je vais pas vous conseiller
de d'aller à une table de poker
mais si vous le faites une fois essayé
de plutôt que de pleurer sur l'argent
perdu parce que je pense qu'il ya plus
de chances que vous perdez que vous
gagnez essayer d'en tirer une leçon de
vie ça c'est ça c'est le premier point
ça me paraît important et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le poker c'est un jeu
de pouvoir
un petit peu comme des choses qu'on
pourrait vivre au quotidien de façon
professionnelle ou personnelle et que ça
vous servent à essayer de profile et les
personnes avec qui vous travaillez votre
boss vos clients vos collègues
pourquoi pas vos amis et que vous
appreniez en tirer profit
alors j'ai dépassé mon temps de parole
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup de
m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]